So if we just plug in our values into Chebyshev's inequality,
we see that x bar should deviate from the true beta star by no more than 0.01,
and the probability of it doing that should be less than or equal to .1.
So if you solve this for n, you get 25,000.
Now this is troubling because we only have about 3,200 points.
So what can we say with 3,200 points?
Well, if all the other parameters are the same.
And we just replace n with 3,200.
The probability that deviation from the true data star is greater than 0.01,
is 0.78 which is pretty high.
However, we can decrease this probability to a more manageable 5%,
if we drop our accuracy bound from 0.01 to 0.0395.
So, just to summarize what we found out.
For our 3,200 data points, if we accept a deviation from the true beta star
of .0395, we can be sure we'll deviate from it with a probability of 5% or less